what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today so we're recording this
youtube intro after watching the episode
because i forgot to record it earlier uh
what you're about to see is a wide
variety of motions here
i currently have a headache for how
intense it becomes my goodness i i i
like my head is pounding from it we're
gonna do a review in a second i wish
more people
watch this show because it's so good
um hit that like button if you end up
enjoying our reaction
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when a reaction the
finale is up full length watch long as
you sync up with the time code or on our
patreon page we cover a whole bunch of
shows over there as well as many of you
guys already know yeah
thank you to uh berthaum or jaden
whoever edited this thank you for
editing this for us the highlights down
enjoy it's a journey
[Music]
why don't you go talk to her and can you
also get light bulbs at the hard
whisperer i can't family hardware went
out of business i know smallville's
really hurting yeah and it's not helping
that the dod is still here
you're that's the heart that's another
that's an open hardware store it's
another store closing
there are no light bulbs anywhere dod
holds smallville hostage
you know about this people want to know
when you're gonna leave when i think
it's safe but i can't say that because
it'll cause a panic if people know that
morgan edge is still out there oregon
edge is the eradicator
is out there gathering power
oh hey car jordan's out back with sarah
oh no actually i'm just uh here for the
open house sorry clark it's just every
time i see you i'm reminded of all that
i'm losing maybe it's a sign you should
stay you're a series regular
so i guess there's no way you're staying
right no we're totally staying
parents are selling your house oh it
doesn't matter they're being ridiculous
they actually believe that moving
somewhere else will you not give us a
fresh start
sophie
shut up sophie wait laser her jordan
yeah
melt her legs off
i got an offer to sell the gazette to
whom some billionaire more like a
multinational conglomerate after edge
our tiny subscriber base got even tinier
so we build a new one
we're a small town paper in a town
that's literally disappearing even
having the world's most famous reporter
can keep the doors open go online
[Laughter]
make an app
all
right worked at the gazette her entire
life just to have it vanish unless
superman starts robbing banks well she
needs a miracle
do it clark you could do it clark
it's crazy how smallville's just
deteriorating
smallville is like a mob
do you think we're giving up too easily
is that what clark said i don't want us
to rush into a decision that we're gonna
regret later not everybody's out to get
us kyle it really seems that way yeah
lately
of everything that the kids have done
for us they've been solid but a lot of
their friendship isn't gonna put food on
the table i know you can't eat friends
lana
he didn't mean literally joe
oh
time to get off the bench bro jimmy's
parents are out of town he's got the
whole place to himself wellness is
picking up a cake as we speak
totally crafty abvs are super high all
right i'm in
yes right bro
six percent
we're gonna go pick up denise and
caitlyn see you boys there yeah oh [ __ ]
they didn't invite her
dude i had promised self to do princess
hair salon you know
earlier
um just all right
call me when you get home yeah
you should have listened to her
heartbeat man i know
see what kind of hornet's nest your
little paper stirred up then let me help
i was hoping you'd say that
general lane is here to answer any
concerns you may have about the
continuing presence of the dod in
smallville when are your soldiers going
to leave our town
[Applause]
that's the question
we're all asking
look everyone i'm sure they have a good
reason for removing it people are afraid
and they want to know that they're safe
can you at least tell us if i was in
custody no he's not
i'm afraid until morgan edge is
apprehended there's reason for concern
but let me assure you
let me assure you dod has been lying for
months
ever since my son died and i have proof
ugh
that's poor guy i'm sorry i feel so
sorry for you
[Laughter]
i want you to know i told the chief in
bristol he'd be lucky to have you i'm
rooting for you
a real change of heart since the last
time we saw you
i was a different woman you racist oh no
i'm just joking i don't remember
did you ever do that to me again
[Music]
he died because of what morgan edge did
that is how he died you have known for
months and you didn't bother saying
anything to me the
guilt
a mother feels that
thinking over and over again what i
could have done differently this is like
the mist
exactly
just gonna lock everyone in here
my team just got a hit on edge
what he just attacked the facility where
laura's being held we need to go
sorry folks but there's a situation
the whole front row heard you
yeah it deserves an answer
just say you're gonna go catch morgan
edge
[Music]
half those extras don't know what's
going on in this trip
we want
what do we want why do we want history
edge is out and he's got laura with him
then we need to warn the town
all right maybe he just wants to hurt me
yeah but if he just wanted to hurt you
why wouldn't he come straight to
smallville i'll reach out make sure they
get back to the farm
oh man they're having beer in here i
know
coming of age
please tell me that's not morgan age
floating up there
oh bird
[Music]
i don't think that's morgan edge anymore
and who is it it's everyone yeah hey
hurry up and grab a drink we got flip
cup out back all right right behind you
right behind you
this is a party
when did you become mr party guy
shouldn't you be building rocket
launchers with john henry or something
it's a missile launcher and
i want to beat wellness and flip come on
come on for a while
[Music]
can we talk can i try a different
extraction method
getting you drunk yeah
i was talking to tamara and uh she got
me thinking that oh maybe you're right
you know maybe maybe this isn't the
right call evie we've built so much here
it's scary to think of walking away from
all this
this is kyle
oh no job offer i'm gonna get that job
we have some news uh your dad just got a
job offer just in a different city which
is why we're gonna have to move to make
it work well the minute it gets hard you
guys are gonna run
oh we are just simply trying to do
what's best for our family maybe you're
not qualified to make that decision i
mean it was you who kissed morgan i just
asked to come here in the first place
i blame you too
okay
why are you here we thought it poetic
that the city you championed to be the
first to fall i know you can't take it
alone toll row
there is no towel row anymore john
picking up four new kryptonian
signatures in the past oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh man
but what's going on at the party
are they drunk
keep an eye on edge
beware of leslie tell me after doesn't
help
get your hammer
aw crap with beginning
everyone you need to get inside and take
cover metropolis is under attack
inside where though
back with gps with janet she went up to
the roof to get a clear shot of the
action no that's where lois died
i've got eyes on two in the business
district that area is heavily populated
everywhere is heavily populated
weapons still yeah dude
super soup's made sure
got one down 17 to journeys and fourth
all right
barely an inconvenience
now trust me you just sell a 42 and
leave the rest of the board hole oh
that guy was shredded by glass shards
oh
nice
my hammer
you're worthy
get it back on reconnecting in 90
seconds
so i feel like maybe you got the wrong
impression of me he got the right
impression mother effort i don't really
think i did to be honest
but i actually did want to hang out with
you
i don't care how many months it takes to
get the answers ever since i moved here
people act like i think i'm better than
this place wait you moved here from
where
central city
central city
my dad
uh oh he was sort of sent to prison
my mom and i decided we needed a fresh
start
who's your dad
it's not really something i tell most
people but then people make assumptions
i think i'm like some sort of
standoffish [ __ ]
kind of come across that way
[Laughter]
it's the resting nature of your face
jordan i need to talk to you yo show
some etiquette cushing shut up corey
get your woman under control
you know bros before host jordan what's
going on
this footage was taken in centennial
park just before the fighting broke out
as you can see superman arrived on the
scene with companions
maybe you should have picked up
granddad's coal
that cbs building looked very familiar
yeah short version morgan edge is taking
over people's bodies and using them to
destroy metropolis janet we need to tell
people what's going on okay it's all on
you janet this is lois lane reporting
live from metropolis where morgan edge
has begun an attack on the city
lois is going to get paid for this right
[Laughter]
at least for the episode
how we doing on time reconnecting in 15
seconds
where the hell is she going
it seems edge has the ability to give
people powers and take over their minds
which is why are you seeing this
important for everyone in metropolis to
find a safe place to take cover until
edge is either apprehended or taken out
oh no
[Laughter]
come on john
come on john
oh
not amazing
my man nice oh dude
oh that was the most badass moment i'd
have a boost that was so badass
i have tears about it
it's very important to keep your eyes
open for any suspicious activity i'm
lois lane reporting live from metropolis
your mom's awesome
yeah
[Laughter]
hell yeah
just chuckles over there
let's finish this yeah
wow
stun doubles uh
he's gone
sir our men are at the kent farm now
boys aren't there
oh man
i i don't want to lose you
i don't either i just don't know how
we're gonna make it work we never see
each other we can call wait we can text
i have super speed i can fly baby soon
i like us but i'm just scared if we do
distance you'll start to hate us
oh
hey grandpa we were i was just about to
call both of you in the car now
not a not a good look can you like tell
us what's happening with morgan edge do
i look like someone who gets classified
intel to drunk teenagers
[Laughter]
a plus my dude
so yeah
oh you're gonna get such good
information out of it
run the dod
i think i can't track down my own
grandsons
oh no
oh
no
save them jordan
it's on you now dude
what a dick move absolute
there's a pistol in the glove
compartment loaded with kryptonite i
need one of your voice to come up here
and get it okay
[Laughter]
try to keep your hands steady
you're only going to get one side of
this
do not miss your chance to blow
oh he's going to catch that bullet
oh don't get him
thank you i know he just
oh jesus i need to go home find your dad
get your dad okay now go go
run there what happened are you okay
thanks for jordan what you need to find
him go
i think this is the most intense thing
i've seen all year
i'm about to cry
oh
oh you son of a [ __ ]
no i don't believe it
that is cruel
fight it
[Applause]
[Music]
lois where are the boys edge took jordan
i looked everywhere he's gone he's
oh damn he totally eradicated the kid
i got a headache
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] it's been good
[Music]
i like it
i don't know
oh it's so gross
yeah
[Music]
well
i told you jordan will become evil
right that's right
episode two or three it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen but exactly as i
predicted i said i said morgan edge is
gonna put his dad inside of jordan said
ten episodes
and it's gonna happen in the second last
episode of the season
it's coming god so predictable
yeah yeah i should have i should have
trusted you this whole time yeah gosh
everyone doubted me
god i wish more people watch this show
god i i really
man i do have a headache
it's not comfortable so it really makes
enough for a comfortable experience to
talk about
they got enough people for season two at
least
or i could just have been wearing the
headphones for too long and then the
yeah they do start to then the intensity
of it all right yeah and you know the
cups around your ears
your head's being squeezed a little bit
yeah
but but
um yes i think that's like the most
intense episode of television i i'd seen
all year and yeah i'm factoring in every
show you've seen us cover this year
but
nothing just it just started feeling so
dark right at the town hall meeting
whenever you would cut to like clark's
shot specifically of just that shot
looking down at him and like
i don't know what to do right now yeah
this is this is like clark just being
lost even himself on the situation like
how do i handle this and then it just
it kept getting worse and worse and i'm
like how do you defeat this guy how do
you defeat edge i don't understand
what you can do and then when he
attacked the carmella or they're gonna
kill one of them off right now what kind
of crap is this no
uh then like lois and then the way how
it was mirroring the moment from when
lois on john harry irons earth died
it it wouldn't the ramping just wouldn't
stop and then in the final moments like
damn that like all hope truly felt lost
if you want to like gear someone up for
a finale like that's how you do it
absolutely just to like superman showing
up back at lois like failing to find his
son and crying and feeling like his son
is gone and like lois in his embrace
so heartbreaking yeah so heartbreaking
that was that was a rough ride it really
was and you could feel like all the
desperation like this this episode i
feel like was laced with a lot of
desperation and then a lot of people
trying to kind of emotionally
fend off
that desperation from taking hold you
know it's from the smaller stakes of
like
you know uh the langs moving or uh you
know lana and kyle talking about moving
up to yeah the town hall meeting where
it's like everyone is sort of boiling
over and losing control and even like
the the meeting between uh uh lois and
oh god chrissy uh
you know the paper about to be sold and
like i have like just everything it
seems like is just
bleeding out of small films yeah and uh
and yeah like that one like i love the
way that they're able to really pull
together their human
stakes and their human decisions with
all the big
action stakes because yeah like
even though you could see it coming like
oh something bad's gonna happen because
they ignored grandpa's phone call like
you know even even just that of like the
the reason they choose to stay at the
party and then the ramifications of that
choice like felt really really natural
and even you know having it come right
down to when ed shows up and and takes
jordan out of the car just the way they
handled
being the people left you know like it
really rings true and i think that those
elements of drama are like so well
captured uh in a show like this that
also yeah again has
you know the the
big scale super stakes that we're used
to this is also doing like a beautiful
multiversal story
uh you know taking you know images like
mirroring an image that we've only seen
in flashbacks to my knowledge in this
particular show uh and then you know
making it really feel like it is a full
circle and everything yeah like this
this really did uh feel like
like a centerpiece for the season almost
yeah you're right
put a lightly yeah you're right i keep
thinking that
morgan edge is i'm gonna totally
just
the show's gonna lose me with him i keep
thinking that
because like especially when i'm so
invested in like the small town [ __ ]
that's going on
everyone's losing their properties
everyone's like going broke here in
smallville they're all turning against
the dod like the real world stakes are
are so gripping just like the drama of
having to give up your home or find
different jobs or you know what's going
to happen between jordan and sarah all
that i'm so invested in
then
when we cut to like morgan edge and
space i was like
weirdly not as interested in this right
now as i am the smaller stuff but then
the way the crescendo all takes place
like when they're in metropolis that
looks great
the action scenes look great if we
didn't go full-on man of steel in that
sequence and there was a little bit of
like i i can see why superman could and
think and uh john henry irons could take
them down they're they're
fairly new to their bodies with their
kryptonians so there's a angle there
where i'm like i could see how they can
knock them unconscious to say the least
uh but the way that was all playing out
was really good action it was really
great and and it took a
it diverted in a different direction
once morgan edge left it was almost as
if this is like a distraction set up so
he can take jordan
because that's like the
you know putting that's like a body
that's a host worthy enough for his
father
and
it's a clever way to get kyle to truly
succumb you know like that is so
it's so despicable that moment and
like watching
evil god morgan edge whatever the hell
he is at the moment
he's got to be he's still got to be edge
or tallow uh because
tallow told row tauro yeah tal row tal
ro
so yeah with tauro because he says
father to him he puts him in his body so
it's not like edge is completely gone
because considering the fact that he
specifically was saying father to him
uh anyway yeah like having the the big
situational metropolis and then you get
the sequence where
edge does attack the vehicle uh with
everyone in there and he was terrifying
it was a terrifying scene you know like
that the way they they bled out the
tension of him like just take the shot
at him and you know it's not going to go
well at all it's like you think of a
bunch of things he's going to catch the
bullet is he just going to just take the
shot and see it not affect him you know
you're not really sure was he going to
retaliate and kill jonathan like your
head starts going and the suspense at
the moment
so they really know how to
like cling on to you in a way where
every time i thought this was going down
off please don't go into too big don't
go too big don't go too cliche don't do
this and then the last few minutes of
this episode just like just started
swerving and i'm like oh i like i love
it for how how uncomfortable it is and
how uh how just how suspenseful all that
is i love that they can re redirect your
emotions and
um redirect what you're anticipating
will take place because it seems like
they're going to walk out on top of the
situation and probably have a good
cliffhanger but nothing as devastating
as what it ultimately came down to you
know because jordan and sarah are
getting along great and i love their
chemistry together and i felt so bad for
sarah like when she's going off on her
parents
like yeah you tell them
you tell them i don't think you're an
annoying teenager
this sucks to be you sarah this sucks to
be in this position it's a shitty
situation to be in yeah and they keep
going so back and forth and everything
oh yeah absolutely so back and forth
we're staying we're not staying you know
i think we're going to say it not going
to stay oh we got the call though we got
the call we're going to go definitely
got to go damn it
damn it like i understand everyone's
predicament i understand everyone's
choice here and i do think the
the drama of it all is cool
what's that girl's name who's like
courting jonathan i go i would love i
was trying to remember it during the
episode someone who belongs in like
riverdale or something really yeah she
doesn't feel like that kind of character
well her dad's got to be someone
specialist at central city where mr
barry allen is from and saying he's in
prison so i'm assuming maybe he's a meta
human of some kind
uh
they're at least teasing him to be
someone significant and i don't want to
read too much into it because it could
just be like whatever
we're just gonna that's the mystery is
central city yeah maybe it was just that
so maybe i'm just reading too far into
it
um their options are always open yeah
but it's saying like we had to move
because my dad went to prison like well
who's your dad you know what
now i'm more interested in that more
than anything else you got to say coming
out of your mouth right now like stuffy
yeah yeah your chemistry is good who's
your daddy
i mean am i supposed to root for them i
can't tell if she is a [ __ ] i really
can't tell either because yeah i mean
you know the problem becomes are you
just really doing a good job of
manipulating me and opening up and
offering vulnerable information just to
draw me in uh but you know i i am i
guess what holds me to that plot line is
that i am rooting for jonathan to have
like a true blue win of his own and you
know maybe some nice chemistry with
somebody it would be neat for jonathan i
think especially because you know in
this episode like that was the kind of
one upbeat for him because even john
henry was like dude
leave me alone and stop making comments
about my life you don't understand
so yeah i i felt for him again and even
little things like that you know yeah
help to bolster the human drama in a way
where
yeah like it does become just as
compelling and then on the opposite side
i like that they kept morgan edge pretty
silent this set like he did a lot with
just his presence alone because the
whole time you're thinking what's he
gonna do he's been absorbing all this
energy and then you know harvesting the
sunlight and charging up these
kryptonian spirits and whatnot and and
he's just
stonewall and it's creepy like it's
really creepy i think that's the other
thing is like they made his presence
very
unsettling besides just the action
destruction of metropolis like like i
kept sitting there going what is going
on with him and what is he gonna do well
there's no emoting and he's so confident
like they're not it's not even a
confidence thing it's
he's
he has nothing to fear yeah he's just so
still he's so he's so he knows he's so
powerful that there's nothing there's
not even a reason to look the slightest
bit worried yeah or show off in anything
yeah yeah and then to put your
protagonist in a situation where you are
concerned for their well-being and to
watch them be worried
makes it that much more effective here
because i i really thought they would
lose me with morgan edge in this episode
of okay he's just terminator
yeah no he's silent evil yeah he's just
gonna make as many other kryptonians as
he can until we punch him super extra
hard but the presence of him is
intimidating um he probably casts a
major shadow like i even love that
shower they first show up in metropolis
and it's just
women leslie larry
she doesn't really have much of a she
does personality character nah she shows
up she looks self-righteous and she's
like morgan edge is gonna kick your ass
you should have joined up
yeah so you have her and then when
morgan edges is floating above them and
like the
the the situation the way they they
dealt with the town hall meeting
and them having to deal with like how
they have a real enemy to deal with and
the good guys are becoming the enemy
because
there's
an issue with what can the public handle
and what can they not handle yeah you
know
and uh like the the the intensity was
already really ramping up from the
moment
they're like and we don't know our
morgan edges and that's why we're here
and then suddenly they get to call it
morgan is it and it's all over
television you know it's it's a really
it's a really crazy it's crazy [ __ ] that
they put together here and i don't know
how they
cause i feel like 99 percent of the time
in any other show
i would be like i don't want to watch
this plot just get back to the good plot
you know and i'm like how how do they
weave this together so well where you
can go to the biggest craziest [ __ ]
happening in metropolis
and then i can be just as engaged when
you go to a high school party and
there's not even really anything
dramatic happening here
you can feel there's a percolating
unease just you're like you know
something bad's going to come yeah even
at this party you're like there's
something so nothing bad happened at the
party
but the the aftermath of having to pull
them away from the party you know was
really bad so
uh yeah i think that's i think that's
the good grip that this show managed to
do with weaving in between all the story
lines was you can tell something worse
is around the corner they've we they've
woven a world where it feels like all of
this stuff in some way affects everybody
and i think that's that's the nice thing
it doesn't feel mechanical like okay now
we need to do a little character
development and now we got to get back
to action
it's like even when you're not focused
on the situation like you know with
kryptonians and whatnot like that does
affect the town in some way and it's
like when you're seeing the kids you're
also kind of aware that they live in the
conversations happening above them with
their parents and stuff like that and
yeah
i would love to be able to distill it
into one thing but it is a fascinating
blend because you know even the debate
constantly about smallville itself
versus metropolis and earlier episodes
about like why they didn't want to move
or you know what's going to be different
about life here and what are the ups and
downs of life in a small town like this
that is struggling you know
even though it's not necessarily why you
come here like they they did i feel like
they have like just the right balance on
how to make that mesh
with you know the impact of all this
super activity while also this being
just you know that being one of many
things these people have to worry about
or whatever well people are going to
find out all about jordan they are i'm
hoping i'm hoping what gets you to
jordan
there's a little girl named sarah i'm
hoping being like jordan
my dad's not taking the job
oh
yeah this is what it's all gonna come
down to at the very end
even if it plays out like that like a
good version of that
i'm still gonna cry
because now at this point all they gotta
do is make the finale not suck and it'll
be great because like yeah like i was
right there with you like this could be
the moment where they reveal like ah
morgan edge you know he's just gonna be
big and evil now and stoic but yeah i'm
like so much more gripped and worried
and fascinated now and that's well they
they really set it up because he messes
up they mess up all the kryptonians they
win and then morgan i just like
piss off whatever
i was expecting
no
that's his power so that's his crazy air
blast fart he does put you in that spot
well i don't know how you're gonna beat
this guy this seems impossible
absolutely it does and i mean props are
like big big props to that actor because
at the beginning of the show and and i
feel like there's been points over the
course of episodes which is kind of
waiting of like okay when is this
character gonna lose me and he's like
every step of the way
been really convincing yeah as each
version of this character yeah is
fantastic yeah i will learn his name and
especially at this point where it's like
you know i have to imagine you know
you're being stoic it has a lot of
impact but for you as an actor you
mostly have to be presence yeah and uh
even then you know like i think he's
killing it yeah
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below what did you think about this
episode um what do you think's gonna
happen in the finale subscribe click
that bell hit that like button
and yeah
let's do a
[Music]
chris wham-off
if there's anyone at our patreon page
who i think
is like
superman
it's
it's got to be chris wham-off it's you
he's the only guy i know at our patreon
who's constantly
trying to help out people in like
strangers
just out of the good of his own heart
wow this shout out is actually tying in
really well in a very sincere way
because it's all true i know
yeah
we don't have to lie like
make up [ __ ] and just fly together
is a great human being he does he is
like a real life hero so much so he
often is like don't even shout me out
just shout out something else worthwhile
worthwhile everett baker
faker
[Laughter]
thank you for um being a real life hero
and um inspiring me when i think about
you but when i'm not thinking about you
i just go around being my own selfish
little self
uh so you know it's uh in the moment
though i go i gotta be more like chris
and then i i forget about it but you at
least have the inclination but in the
moment i do feel guilted into trying to
be a better person so thank you for that
[Music]